let's put it this way you you
describe yourself as being interested
in navigating correctly navigating
issues of
what we might otherwise call diversity
equity and inclusion without
involved in without getting involved in
what we
recognize as the culture war you are not
absolutely alone in this squadron you
are uh
you are friends with chloe valderi so
she's a mutual friend of ours
and i would say that you are both
interested in figuring out
you know sorting the wheat from the
chaff in this area rather than just
pretending that there is no issue of
diversity equity and inclusion
right and you know i i share that belief
with you there is something to be
navigated and unfortunately both polls
are wrong about it it's not that we
don't have a problem
right but it is also not that you know
white supremacy is
uh ubiquitous in in america and the west
and it has to be
stamped out along with patriarchy and
and all of those
uh false uh assertions
i have to yeah well you know uh this um
the constant refrain of white supremacy
um it's so sad for all kinds of reasons
but one of the big reasons for me
is that uh first of all you know my
family
are refugees from uganda in east africa
we were booted out
by a black man idi amin who
decided that africa belongs
only to blacks
well guess what folks uh my family had
been
in uganda for three generations
uh we did not know any other country
we did not have a passport to india or a
passport to britain
uganda was our country
but you know the the the very legitimate
aspiration to liberation
in the various african colonies devolved
as
aspirations often do into a fever
called pan-africanism and that is when
you get the dogma
and dogma by definition is exclusionary
so no wonder that you know
a military dictator could tell
other people of color you do not
belong here and part of what is so
frustrating
for somebody who has been born in a
completely different
uh segment of the world coming to the
united states
is that even those who decry
western imperialism or who
uh you know castigate um
others for quote centering whiteness
they themselves don't recognize that
these impulses to exclude
are human they are
endemically human and that if you're
gonna go around
preaching to others to check their bias
the question becomes what bias of yours
are you checking role model that
show that and that's
again not what we see so in a way brett
i feel like this whole uh cultural
moment
sort of focusing on diversity equity
inclusion and the like
is missing something huge a huge
opportunity and the opportunity is this
right now it's as if there are two rival
teams on the field
one used to wear the jersey called
powerful
and the other used to wear the uniform
uh
labeled powerless now those jerseys are
being swiped uh swapped out okay they're
being
traded but you have the same
game we have the opportunity right now
to change the us against them game
through diversity equity and inclusion
and that is
not what we are doing we're replicating
the game
right we are replicating the game it's
not as if this isn't a known
pattern i mean i sort of feel like there
are places where the right lesson is
encoded
right there are things you will find in
orwell that are absolutely central to
our moment
you know the who covered this particular
one meet the new boss
same as the old boss and the idea is we
have this
tendency to valorize the oppressed which
is understandable but the problem is
your point is exactly right there is
a quadrant of human nature that acts
in a particular way based on its
opportunities once it gains power
and so to the extent that we view the
oppressed as
more deserving they may be more
deserving but at the point that you
transfer who's powerful
to them they behave in the same ways
because guess what this had nothing to
do
with their particular genes creating
particular defects of cognition
this has to do with game theory the
powerful tend to behave this way unless
you build systems in which it doesn't
pay
if you build those systems we can behave
much better and many of us have seen
that world we have
lived in these circumstances where
frankly race has been sidelined
and we've seen how well it works and
it's very
frustrating to have the
functional world that we might live in
prototyped
all around the landscape but when it
comes time to say
actually here's how we ought to
structure things so that race is not a
dominant predictor of your
well-being for example we end up shouted
down
by those who are playing a game that
whether they are cynical
the game is cynical right exactly
leveraging power in order to get limited
resources
you know making hay while the sun shines
and this is
you know this was a disaster a hundred
years ago
but it's actually an existential threat
now because if you play that game
in a world where people are as
thoroughly armed as they are
and in which these tendencies are so
amplified by technologies that we did
not evolve
with this is going to result in a this
being a very short ride
so we have a limited amount of time to
fix this it's not like
you know we can go through another
couple genocides and uh
then figure it out actually the time is
now
right right um it's so interesting um
i wanted to pick up on something you
just said about how
uh you know we've we've seen where this
can lead
right um i have a very good friend who
wrote a fantastic piece
about the re-segregation that is
happening
in various schools across the country to
to kids
you know third and fourth graders being
sort of divided up physically divided up
uh in sort of the white quadrant
the you know black quadrant the bipark
uh
quadrant etc etc and
um one of the people who
advocates this kind of thing is
was the bridesmaid to the friend who
wrote about
who wrote scathingly about this and one
of my friends
saw that her former bridesmaid was on
board
with this divvying up of kids she asked
her former bridesmaid
what gives what happened and
the educator who you know advocates this
kind of uh
resegregation said well i'm proud
to be working at a school that is
willing to try
new things to try old things really to
try
how does it not occur to her that we
did try this and it was bad
how does an educator not realize that
this is
not a new thing it's an old thing
yes tell me how that happens brett well
i
i wish i knew and you know of course i
um
rather famously lived this exact
phenomenon as i watched
my college embrace segregation
i did the obvious thing which was to
point out that this wasn't a good idea
and i became you know the sort of symbol
for white supremacy on my campus because
i was against
segregation i mean that that is such a
bizarre
uh experience to go through right if you
had told me
at 35 that that was going to happen to
me
you know on the cusp of 50
right that i was going to be demonized
as a racist for fighting
segregation i would have thought you
completely bonkers
right likewise if you had told me 10
years ago
that we would be having a fight over
whether or not
there was a sexual binary that was uh
supported by scientific evidence i mean
this
couldn't possibly be a more secure
conclusion has nothing to do with humans
it goes back 500 million years in our
lineage alone
right how could we possibly find
ourselves fighting over that
or the idea that in mathematics we would
be fighting over whether or not two plus
two indeed
equals four in some fundamental way like
how did we allow the very basic
rules for memory or
extrapolation to be taken from us
so now let me ask a kind of a
provocative question okay to the both of
us
and i myself don't yet have an answer
by uh literally because the question is
this
what are we missing what are you and i
not getting that so many others
get i'd really i'm very open
yeah to exploring this
well so let me say i want to be careful
because i feel like
there are certain things that we could
say almost for sure okay
we're missing 90 of the story
you and me okay or that that's because
we're doing well
right the fact that it you know we might
be getting 10 of it is is
par for the course actually that doesn't
mean
that the object that sounds like the one
you're describing
actually exists because i don't think we
are
missing it i think the point is we have
been invited to a game
that were we to say you know what we're
probably powerless to stop the game
so we might as well play to win right if
you wanted to win
the diversity equity and inclusion game
so that at the point that it collapses
which i would argue is
absolutely inevitable when that game
collapses
you know you could have three homes
maybe if you played your cards right
right um and so the question is
not what are we missing the question is
why would we fail to play the game
when the alternative is to effectively
play
cassandra and to warn of something
that's coming
and have it not create the impact that
could prevent it
well in part i know why
i refuse to play by the rules of the
game
um one of the reasons there are many
but one of the reasons i refuse to play
by the rules
is that um as i mentioned you know my
family and i are refugees to this part
of the world
and i can say without a shadow of a
doubt
that it has been uh our good fortune
to wind up here um
every morning before i pull my sorry
butt out of bed
i think uh god
i am a person of faith uh
i thank god that you know we wound up in
a part of the world
where as somebody with all of my labels
um as somebody who nonetheless
has been given the opportunities
and has recognized them
as opportunities and has
taken the opportunities to
develop a voice to become
something of a thought leader um
i i really believe brett that most
people in our society have
those opportunities i see
how you know students of color for
example
in uh urban centers where i've i've
taught
are being pumped with the narrative
that not only are they victims but now
quite apart from their skin color now
they are also along with white kids
fragile
so that even being exposed
to a different perspective one that
challenges
the narrative that they're being you
know filled with
is harming them and a lot of these kids
actually don't feel harm but they're
thinking to themselves well
if i'm supposed to be harmed then
i guess i better act that way because
that's what's expected of me
so we're creating these false
uh divisions and um
intentions uh and for what
for the adults to
uh build stature upon this pile of
[Music]
falsifications